Here our solutions set is negative 2 and positive 6. That's amazing work if
you've found those two answers. First we want to square both sides of our
equation. 2 squared equals 4, times the quantity 2x plus 4, since the square of
this square root is simply what's inside here. On the right side, we'll square
the binomial x plus 2 to get this expression. Next we'll distribute the 4 to
get 8x plus 16 on the left, and our same expression on the right. We want to
set our quadratic equal to 0, so we subtract 8x from both sides, and we
subtract 16 from both sides. This leaves us with 0 equals x squared minus 4x
minus 12. Now, we're ready to try and factor. We find factors of negative 12
that sum to negative 4. Those factors are negative 6, and positive 2. We set
each factor equal to 0 to get x equals 6, or x equals negative 2 as our
potential solutions to the original radical equation. Finally, we check each of
the solutions in the original equation and discover they both check. This means
we can include both of these numbers in our answer to have our final solution
set.